hey olivia what's up good morning hey
what are you guys doing outside my house
ah come on you know we love you
listen olivia what's going on let me ask
you there's so much happening do you
think ryan should be canceled for
dressing up like a japanese person
i'm not really into cancer culture ah
all right
all right what do you got to say to the
fans what's going on what are you
working on right now
lots of stuff i can't talk about yeah of
course
yeah that's right i don't know ryan
dressed up though like a geisha in
seventh grade that was very insensitive
hey madison what's up ladies guess who
yes you're madison you're never gonna
guess what i have in my possession right
now what do you have
i have your report card from last year
you
failed chemistry that class was hard
your mother paid for a tutor
talk to me man what's going on what's up
man what are you doing man
dude what's next for you that's what
everybody wants to know it's like what's
next for you oh i really want to become
an actor
an actor yeah man so what type of acting
are you trying to do
uh like you know like i feel like where
you're like talking
yeah yeah i feel that man i feel that yo
geo what's up fam what uh
what's up what's going on with you and
ashley bro i mean
you know i can't really speak on that
right now i'm just just focused on the
music
yeah what kind of music you gonna put
out uh
it's like it's that new [ __ ] yeah like
like what like
little dicky meets enya [ __ ] yeah man
yeah are you okay to drive yeah i'm good
all right sam
you sure you're good bro i'm good look
at her recorder mid-tick-tock
so what's going on you think we're going
to war with china
it's not falling out me and my friends
you're literally like 50 years old
please get out
leave go go go yeah miss you you took a
trip back home what was that like
yeah i wasn't good man my mom just
passed away uh to covet so oh man that
doesn't slap no it doesn't
no rip mom you know what i'm saying yeah
that's right
rip mom yeah